the Fox News text message leaks have
gone nuclear and the latest tranche
reveals that Tucker Carlson hates Trump
passionately despite acting on his show
like he thinks Trump is a reasonable
person and hanging out with Trump
outside of work and pretending to like
him as well this exposes so many
different layers of the insanity that is
right wing media the right wing movement
and the Maga movement in the United
States and we're going to look at all of
it but let's start with what we learned
Huffington Post reports Tucker Carlson
exposed says he hates Trump quote
passionately
in private texts the Fox News host said
he deplored the former president in
private and wished for the day he could
ignore him these are text messages from
right before the Trump riots uh text
messages from January 4th 2021 we are
going to look at a number of the
different messages these again have been
revealed in connection with the Dominion
voting systems lawsuit for defamation
against Fox News take a look at this
Tucker texting with an unknown person
we are very very close to being able to
ignore Trump most nights I truly can't
wait
the person that Tucker is texting with
says I want nothing more it does feel
very close very close I imagine things
will get nice starting around
mid-February to which Tucker Carlson
responds I hate him passionately I blew
up at Peter Navarro today in frustration
I actually like Peter but I can't handle
much more of this
Tucker hates Trump and we will get to
the
uh uh
hypocrisy and interest of this uh very
very soon
Tucker and Laura Ingram also texting and
it is fascinating Laura Ingram saying to
Tucker Friday numbers aren't that
surprising with Trump impending loss but
how much of the bleed is due to anger at
the news channel this is Laura texting
Tucker about the decline in ratings
right around that time right after the
election in November of 2020. Tucker
says oh a lot meaning a lot of the
ratings decline is because of people
angry that the news side of fox called
the election for Biden and rightly so
Laura says my anger at the news channel
is pronounced and Tucker says it should
be we devote Our Lives to building an
audience and they let Chris Wallace and
Leland effing vidert wreck it too much
Tucker mad
at Chris Wallace because Chris Wallace
actually said some uncontroversial
truths
um and then in a third one here
um Tucker Carlson saying the downside of
the business of the news business is
that a lot of the time you don't get to
choose the news but you're required to
react to it so we actually do earn our
salaries now then uh oh sorry this is
from uh from unknown person they pitch a
podcast to Tucker saying one thought I
had today is a joint venture of sorts
between Tucker Carlson LLC and Fox News
podcasts generally are free and AD
supported we could have a fox backed
podcast promoted on channel Etc that has
one free episode a week and we can
repurpose tuckercarlson.com to host the
podcast and create a Tucker Carlson
podcast app blah blah blah blah blah we
get people to subscribe etc etc and uh
basically pitching a business to Tucker
Carlson while all of this insane
discussion is going on and he's furious
with Trump and he hates him passionately
and on and on and on these are merely
actors and entertainers okay now as a
reminder of course here is Tucker a few
months ago hanging out with Trump at a
golf tournament and Tucker and Marjorie
Taylor green also they look like they're
having a grand old time with Trump so we
this is not a trivial thing to
understand
sometimes people think you know David
it's like there's what you do and
there's The Young Turks and there's Fox
News and there's all this different
stuff it's all the same it is not all
the same Tucker is more like a character
in a movie on his show someone who will
pretend whatever to maintain the show
and the salary that comes with it to
maintain ratings and to maintain access
to power in this case access to power
means being able to hang around Trump
have Trump on whatever the case may be
I believe the things I say I'm not
playing a character on this show and I
think that you will find that this is
the case with just about everybody uh
that you know I would consider a
colleague that is sort of in the field
in the business that I'm in of uh online
left-wing political commentary and
Analysis when I tell you something on
the show
I'm not playing a character and
sometimes people in my audience don't
like it for example last week and the
week before I did Clips telling you I'm
not super interested in this Marianne
Williamson candidacy I find her new age
spiritual stuff to be nonsense I don't
think she's going to do anything to push
Biden left I'm not really entertained or
interested or think that the entire
thing is is a super valuable thing it
would be easier for me to do the things
some other shows do which is to say this
is incredibly important Marianne
Williams Williamson is an important
voice and she is a valuable participant
in the Democratic primary and once she
gets on the debate stage with Joe Biden
she's going to show people how valuable
that would be me lying to you and
playing a character and I would get
praise for doing that
if you look online you know Jesse dollar
more has been critical of Marianne
Williamson and he's getting attacked on
Twitter it would be easier for me to
play the character okay but I don't do
that I just tell you what I think and
sometimes there are repercussions and
sometimes people get mad and sometimes
people tune out
Fox News we've now learned Tucker hates
Trump but was still playing up all of
the election lies and he hangs out with
Trump Etc Sean Hannity didn't believe
any of the nonsense he was spouting
Laura Ingram didn't believe the nonsense
she was pounding drowning his own
country to make a buck now will this
affect Tucker's audience in the sense
that now they know the guy I'm a trump
fan and I watch Tucker to get the news
about him now that they know Tucker
actually hates Trump
are they going to tune out or will they
even know that Tucker hates Trump maybe
not